[Musique]
natacha polony bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle signerions
voudrais avoir votre avis sur le
journalisme vous avez créé récemment un
think tank qui s'appelle vous avez
assumé la présidence d'un sultan qui
s'appelle le comité orwell qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire c'est un comité
qui s'est fondée à quelques journalistes
mais non parce que sur votre site
internet c'est pas très bien fait on
n'arrive pas à avoir accès à toutes les
informations du board de ce think tank
là alors c'est très simple sur une idée
originale de jean michel 4 points
alexandre ii vecchio qui est au figaro
et au figaro vox emmanuel lévy qui est à
marianne franck dedieu qui est l
expansion et voilà a priori la petite
équipe de départ c'était ça benjamin
massot rentrant berger aussi et puis on
a comme ça
au fur et à mesure agglutinés les
énergies pourquoi parce que au départ
c'étaient des discussions entre nous où
nous nous disions que le journalisme tel
qu'il est pratiqué ne nous plaisait pas
que nous avions
cette sensation assez désagréable que
certains sujets ne sont jamais traités
ne sont pas traités comme ils devraient
l'être qu'il y a non pas une chape de
plomb comme ça a pu être le cas à un
moment donné vraiment je pense dans les
années 90 2000 chefs de plan idéologique
alors là épouvantable les choses ont
bougé mais en tout cas qu'il y avait et
qu'il y a une façon de ne pas poser les
problèmes de ne pas les traiter qui est
la négation de l'idée qu'on se faisait
du journalisme donc nous avons
eu envie de réfléchir à la pratique
journalistique de réfléchir à la façon
dont les idées pouvaient être agité dont
les informations pouvaient sortir
nous avons lancé un texte une sorte de
manifeste et se manifeste a recueilli
énormément d co donc est-ce que vous
avez énormément des coupes énormément
des causses aveu 10 cents abonnés sur
votre page facebook voilà des 240
abonnés sur la page youtube exactement
105 vue sur votre colloque
d'ouverture oui oui c'est il me semble
que d'arriver à mobiliser 250 personnes
dans un colloque c'est quand même pas
non plus
quelque chose d'évident on a reçu
énormément de messages de gens nous
disons bravo merci de réfléchir à ça je
pense que healy a aujourd'hui une
insatisfaction énorme de la part des
français sur ce que sont les médias il y
a une impression de ne pas être
informées une impression que croisiens
wii wiiware réellement réellement une
forme de trahison et
l'idée que
les médias jouent un rôle de chien de
garde
donc je pense que j'aime dans ce qui
tient de garde d'un système chaîne garde
de on va dire d'un système qui pour
reprendre la phrase de warren buffett
est une véritable lutte des classes et
que les riches sont en train de gagner
je pense qu'il ya de ça vous avez vous
avez
posé des questions à christine ockrent
concernant les réseaux de pouvoir le
cercle bildenberg oui quand ça vous ai
vue de l'esprit nous personnellement les
connaît on a travaillé avec certains qui
ont participé au bilderberg qui compile
y compris de la commission trilatérale
donc soit souvent hervé de carmoy qui
vit et qui était vice-président de la
commission trilatérale europe
ce sujet des cercles de pouvoir n'est
vraiment pas aborder ça vous est venue l
idée comment est la réaction qui a eu en
face de vous c'était naturel c'était
comment c'était violent on va dire je
pense que là encore elle vous a pris
pour une conne non seulement elle m'a
prise pour une conne mais elle m'a prise
surtout pour quelqu'un qui n'avait pas à
poser ce genre de questions et qui tout
à coup faisait surgir quelque chose qui
ne doit pas surgir au milieu d'un
on va dire d'un débat convenu entre gens
bien le ronron c'est ça mais vous savez
c'est c'est valable pour ce genre de
question pour comment ça m'est venu de
parler du réseau bilderberg parce que
tout simplement
j'ai lu en travaillant sur elle qu'elle
en avait fait partie
je me suis posé la question de savoir
quelle était la place d'un journaliste
dans ce genre de cercle qu'est-ce qu'on
venait y chercher pourquoi est il très
sain qu'un journaliste soit dans les
mêmes réseaux de fréquentation et d'
influence que des chefs d'entreprise ddd
politique est ce que réellement ça lui
rapporte de l'information
non il n'y a aucun but informatif là
dedans puisque justement le principe est
que ce qui est dit ne sortent pas donc
ce n'est pas pour aller chercher de
l'information
ce n'est pas pour aller comprendre le
fonctionnement de
bon va dire des
des systèmes politiques et économiques
parce que je pense qu'on peut les
comprendre parfaitement sans cela donc
ce que vous avez déjà assisté un type de
réunion de cette ampleur-là de ce niveau
là non vous êtes déjà est-ce que vous
avez déjà été dans un cercle
de ce niveau là on entre très
honnêtement non mais je pense que je n'y
serai pas pour une raison simple c'est
que justement je ne pratique pas mon
métier de journaliste de cette façon
c'est à dire que je ne pense pas que la
proximité avec les hommes politiques par
exemple m'apporte quoi que ce soit dans
ma façon de traiter les questions
politiques et de réfléchir au rôle que
jouent les politiques au choix qui sont
les leurs vos collègues vos collègues le
sérail journalistique a fait corps avec
vous derrière vous allez ses
côtés sur la nature
comment vous dire
j'ai toujours été un peu à part dans le
milieu journalistique où j'ai travaillé
pour peut-être parce que justement je
n'ai pas un parcours de journaliste
je n'ai pas fait d'école de journalistes
moi j'ai une agrégation de lettres
évidemment j'ai fait sciences po aussi
mais à un moment où j'avais déjà
enseigné où j'avais j'étais professeur
donc mon parcours il est plus agréable
de lettres que
que sciences po et j'ai continué à
enseigner ensuite en même temps que je
pratiquais le journalisme donc peut-être
que ça m'a donné une façon de traiter
les problèmes à ses différentes on m'a
parfois reproché
parmi mes collègues de trop
intellectualiser de troupes éditorialisé
c'est à dire qu'on ait fait j'assume la
pratique d'un journalisme d'opinion que
j'ai appris à marianne avec jean
françois kahn qui m'a toujours expliqué
que c'est une tradition française que
ça n'a jamais dérangé personne quand il
s'agissait de jaurès de clemenceau dans
tout ce qu'on veut et que c'est une
c'est une façon de
de respecter le lecteur il sait d'où
l'on parle pour revenir sur le comité en
rouelles et sur les journalistes
ja il ya un problème ça c'est sur la
question je vous ai posé quand j'ai été
agitée au comité orwell c'est si le
comité orwell c'est à dire ceux cette
prise de conscience cette émergence de
prise de conscience de la profession ne
fonctionne pas qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer et je vous ai répondu
la révolution et je le crois
profondément c'est à dire que je pense
que dans ce que christopher lasch
appelait la sécession des élites c'est à
dire le fait que nous avons aujourd'hui
partout dans le monde des élites qui
n'ont plus les mêmes intérêts et
objectifs que les peuples des pays
auxquels ils appartiennent dans ce cadre
là si on continue à accepter cette
fracture a laissé se déliter les ont va
dire le bien commun et la préservation
du bien commun au sein des nations je
pense qu'on va vers des mouvements
violents je pense qu'une consent une
colère qui monte une colère qui peut
s'exprimer de façon très diverse
personne ne sait ce qui peut se passer
mais
il est évident que les élections
américaines les élections françaises et
des élections partout en europe nous
montre que les peuples cherchent pour
l'instant tout de même à travers
l'exercice démocratique mais peut-être
de moins en moins à faire entendre leur
voix à reprendre le pouvoir ou en tout
cas à faire comprendre aux élites que
ils se sont aperçus qu'on leur avait
pour l'heure avait pris le pouvoir
qu'on les prenait pour des cons tout
simplement oui on les prenait pour des
cons ben oui mais que les intérêts que
les interactions tous sont divergents
tout simplement et qu'on s'assied sur la
démocratie donc on peut pas s'asseoir
sur la démocratie très très très
longtemps il ya un moment où ça marche
plus les préconisations pour améliorer
faire s'il ya des conseils à faire
passer à vos collègues
peut-être la formation intellectuelle me
pousserait tel à dire que la première
préconisation serait de lire ce raid
développer une culture générale une
curiosité qui permet d'avoir un tout
petit peu de recul sur les discours qui
sont produits des petit cours
d'autodéfense intellectuelle oui c'est
ça c'est quand même grave le conseiller
c'est un journaliste il a oublié sa la
charte de munich il y avait eu il y a
quelques années dont le nombre
diplomatique une enquête très
intéressantes sur les écoles de
journalisme
je me rate je ne me rappelle pas le nom
du journaliste au brésil oui oui mais il
expliqué à quel point il y avait une
chose qui manquait furieusement dans les
écoles de journalisme ce sont les
bibliothèques et je pense que cette
une des dimensions importantes du
problème c'est à dire que jusqu'à
présent les journalistes enfin le
journalisme n'était pas tout à fait une
profession comme les autres genres un
jour je me suis pris la tête avec
servan-schreiber et j'ai objecté c'est à
l'époque de la farce assange et le
partenariat entre les maisons de presse
et wikileaks pour traiter les câbles et
j'étais un petit peu en train de
tricoter sur l'indépendance des
journalistes et sa grande tirade a été
mais vous objecter l'indépendance des
journalistes mois durant ma longue
carrière je n'ai jamais senti la lèze du
pouvoir se tendre sur les journalistes
là on est en 2016 parce qu'il ya une
laisse coût des journalistes c'est à
dire que pour ne pas sentir la laisse se
tendre est sûr qu'il va tirer dessus oui
se sentir seuls le recul qu'on sent rien
de douche
mais
bien sûr qu'il y ait une laisse il y à
une laisse d'abord
j'allais dire simplement économique la
situation actuelle des médias fait que
les journalistes sont sous dépendance
parce qu'ils sont en permanence menacés
de perdre leur travail tout simplement
de faire ce qu'ils étaient en train de
se passer dans le groupe de l'express et
l'expansion c'est une saignée absolue
c'est à dire qu'on a des journalistes
qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent sur le
carreau cd ou d'épuration
pour l'instant jeudi une saignée parce
que je ne sais pas exactement quels sont
les choix qui sont à l'oeuvre mais en
tout cas je pense en effet que sa relève
j'allais dire
je serai pas forcément immédiatement
malveillantes dans ma façon prendre les
choses dans le sens où je ne pense pas
forcément qu'il y ait une épuration
idéologique parce que je crois que
malheureusement
l'idéologie première c'est l'économisme
c'est à dire l'idée qu'on va réduire les
coûts c'est tout ça est fait par des
gens qui n'ont aucune notion de choquer
une entreprise de presse qui ne ce
qu'ils se foutent complètement de la
spécificité du travail d'un journaliste
mais il continue à investir venant
pourtant sa paire du fric à la il reste
encore une dimension de prestige et de
poids politique dans le fait de posséder
un média même si on perd du fric même
pas seulement de propagande même pas
seulement c'est simplement l'idée que
l'on pèse dans son rapport avec des
politiques et avec d'autres
milieux économiques ce qui va lancer une
chaîne youtube beaucoup d'abonnés
exacte est
on a reçu denis robert plusieurs
reprises qu'est ce que vous pensez de
données en verre
écoutez je
j'aurais dû j'aurai du mal à avoir un
jugement définitif parce que c'est
quelqu'un que je n'ai jamais rencontré
j'ai suivi son travail j'ai été
intéressé par son travail après
je ne prétendrai pas spécial et ceux du
sujet et je parle et quand je ne
maîtrise pas suffisamment ce dont je
parle n'avait pas vu son fils blanquette
non je n'ai pas vu sur film enquête dont
vous êtes au courant de son travail
quand il a commencé à remuer un petit
peu la merde des chambres de
compensation avec le luxembourg il s'est
fait un peu lapidé par votre corporation
alors comment ça se fait qu'il ya pas de
solidarité entre journalistes et journal
quand il faut c'est à dire quand
louis ou quand il s'agit de d'expliquer
en fin de de prendre des airs outré par
ce que telle ou telle par exemple telle
ou telle politique dénonce justement des
journalistes
trop proche du pouvoir là tout à coup on
a vraiment des comment mais vous
attaquez les journalistes c'est un
scandale donc non il ya un corporatisme
évident mais en effet il joue pas
forcément la wii devrait sur l'est alors
on va reprendre un dossier un peu plus
frais paul moreira sur l'ukraine se fait
ramasser un peu sur les réseaux sociaux
côté journalistes
ces faits adulé par exemple partie de
l'internet par rapport à son
indépendance d'esprit
pour ceux qui ont du sens documentaire
votre avis là dedans en tant que
présidente du comité ruelle est ce qu'on
a le droit de traiter tous les sujets il
est évident qu'on n'a pas le droit de
traiter tous les sujets c'est à dire
bien sûr qu'il ya une espèce de on va
dire de on pas de censure mais de
comment dire de façon très claire de
faire sentir qu'il ya des choses dont on
ne peut pas parler et des choses qu'il
ne faut pas aller fouiller que tout à
coup on sort de ce que à la main qu'ils
appellent le cercle de la raison oui la
police de la pensée oui bien sûr bien
sûr et
7,7 police de la pensée elle est
extrêmement puissante dans la mesure où
il s'agit avant tout de faire passer
celui qui a
débordé des limites conspirationnistes
un conspirationniste un incompétent un
quelqu'un dont qui ne qui tout à coup
n'a rien à faire à la table des gens
sérieux vous connaissez arthur
schopenhauer
arthur schopenhauer oui l'art d'avoir
toujours raison oui bien sûr vous n'avez
pas l'impression que c'est un petit peu
le livre de chevet de tous ces
intellectuels médiatiques
fait prendre le contrôle de la
dialectique grâce à des stratagèmes
alors à ceci près que qu'est ce qu'on
appelle intellectuels médiatiques et qui
désigne ton par là c'est à dire que le
concept d'intellectuels médiatiques en
ce moment il est utilisé aussi pour
disons comme une arme et pour
décrédibiliser certains voiliers c'était
un concept à géométrie variable
intellectuels médiatiques quand
l'intellectuel médiatique c'est bhl ou
alain minc
finalement ça ne dérange pas mais en ce
moment les ce qu'on appelle
intellectuels médiatiques c'est ce que
najat vallaud belkacem a appelé les
pseudos intellectuels c'est à dire ce
qu'ils pensent mal ce qui eu le mauvais
goût de critiquer la réforme du collège
et là tout à coup un intellectuel
médiatique était une forme de
dévalorisation voyez donc c'est pour ça
que le concept parquet de coiffer qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour aller récupérer cette
indépendance d'esprit et les traiter les
sujets nécessaire pour avoir un prisme
de lecture profonds ont fait un syndicat
de journalistes
sur armé intellectuellement parlant on
fait des groupes de pression fécamp
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour nous on
a tendance un petit peu ravagé votre
profession ils savent pertinemment que
quand ils viennent commenter les choses
chez nous s'ils n'ont pas les toffes ou
la trempe d'un denis robert il se fond
vaporiser
on aimerait quand même un peu vous aider
on fait quoi nous l'internet on va
protéger les journalistes ont fait le
boulot de on fait quoi qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour vous aider je pense que
vous le travail que vous faites le
travail qui se trouve sur internet
ne doit pas venir en aide aux
journalistes c'est une alternative c'est
une autre façon de produire de
l'information et de la pensée simplement
moi j'ai une attache pour le journalisme
classique et en particulier de presse
écrite dont je pense que pour l'instant
il n'est pas encore remplacé son rôle
exact ne pourrait pas être être grande
de la presse écrite oui vous connaissez
la capacité d'un algorithme agrégé de
l'information et à écrire un article
mais un algorithme ne remplacera jamais
ce que moi je vais chercher dans de la
presse écrite à savoir non pas seulement
de l'information mais du reportage de la
pensée du jugement même saissac apporte
que qu'est censée apporter la presse
qu'elle ne fait pas parce que le
reportage on n'a plus d'argent pour en
faire la pensée mais encore faut-il
pouvoir l'articuler donc voilà c'est
tout donc je pense que healy a
aujourd'hui une forme de journalisme low
cost qui est en train de se développer
avec nation parmi libéralisation du
journal avait totalement totalement il
suffit de voir comment les dans les
rédactions de presse quotidienne le
modèle du numérique est en train de
dicter sa loi aux journalistes de presse
écrite de même que les chaînes
d'information continue ont dicté leur
mode de fonctionnement au reste du
journalisme c'est à dire que là le temps
long le recul sont en train de
disparaître ce qui compte aujourd'hui
pour un journaliste c'est de produire le
plus vite possible pour faire de l'
alerte smartphones mais même dans des
grands quotidiens nationaux donc je
pense que c'est contre cela qu'il faut
lutter c'est d'ailleurs vous avez un
travail journalistique sur le net qui
arrive à lutter contre ça mais qui pour
l'instant vivote ne serait-ce que ce
matin dans ma revue de presse je citais
le site ulysse ce qui est une entre le
journalisme et l'édition mais qui fait
du temps nom qui fait de l' enquête qui
fait du récit mais il me semble que ça
c'est un modèle c'est une des formes du
journalisme qui malheureusement est en
train d'être éradiquée des médias
classiques pourquoi
questions économiques pas une question
est question aussi de capacité du public
à se donner la peine de lire j'ai
interviewé le directeur de la télévision
publique russe en russie bon j'ai un peu
chauffé sur la liberté de la presse sur
des gens qui disparaît suis ce sont des
choses qui arrivent bon ça arrive mais
bon comment se comporter les
journalistes russes pour inquiéter des
choses comme ça et puis en partant il me
dit tu sais par l'intermédiaire d'un
traducteur il faut donner non parce que
les gens ont besoin mais ce que les gens
veulent
questions philosophiques ça le savoir
france on leur donne quoi karl popper
s'est posé la question de savoir si
en matière de télévision par exemple la
démocratie consistait à donner aux gens
ce qu'ils veulent et je crois que
tout cela est
moi je ne crois pas oui alors on fait
quoi pourquoi parce que mes jeux mais je
précise pourquoi parce que sans un
peuple éduqué la démocratie c'est la
tyrannie des imbéciles donc donner aux
gens ce qu'ils veulent en faisant en
sorte qu'il ne veuille que des choses
simples distrayante facile parce qu'on
les a abrutis et qu'on a fait en sorte
de détruire l'outil d'éducation quelle
école ça n'est plus de la démocratie si
on passe le point de non-retour
d'abêtissement de la population est dans
une sorte de la démocratie et c'est bien
le problème et c'est bien ce qui
m'inquiète et on en est pas loin l'état
d'urgence pour vous c'est quoi l'état
d'urgence était une des façons
d'agiter la masse de faire croire au bon
peuple qu'on le protège en évitant de se
poser les véritables problèmes la
déchéance de nationalité
bonne chose c'était quand même un mois
que les médias sont à temps plein sur
une question absolument ridicule il faut
que ça passe c'est tout mais pas
pourquoi il faut déchoir quelqu'un de sa
nationalité
est ce que vous avez parce que vous avez
étudié un petit peu à partir de 2001
tous et tous les executive order
américain le patriot act gens tout
l'arsenal législatif autour de
l'emprisonnement la torture le
kidnapping et l'assassinât parce que
c'est pas plus facile pour un état
français maintenant d'aller demander des
informations d'une façon un peu plus
prédatrice sur un détenu parce que comme
il sera plus protégé par notre
constitution il aura une extra
territorialité de ces justice parce que
c'est pour ça que les médias sont en
train de nous devons faire manger
pendant un mois après on va attraper les
terroristes il fallait les faire parler
mais si on fait parler un terroriste qui
d'origine française on va peut-être pas
pouvoir le torturer comme on pouvait
torturé
un sauvage déchu du sénat souligne
nationalité alors peut-être suis-je un
peu naïve ou peut-être suis-je beaucoup
plus pessimiste que vous sur les
journalistes c'est pas vrai mais j'ai
tendance à penser que ce n'est même pas
ça le problème
oui que le problème la raison pour
laquelle les journalistes s'agit de
puits en moi là dessus c'est parce que
le marigot politique
les fascine c'est parce que de savoir si
hollande a mis un poignard dans le dos
de sarkozy et si la droite va
politique
uniquement ça uniquement ils vont pas du
tout allait réfléchir aux implications
réelles là dans le journalisme à
sensation qu'il ya une hiérarchie
il ya une hiérarchie implicite
tout en haut il ya les journalistes
politiques les autres c'est le nom de
ben prolétariat en particulier les
journalistes sur les questions de
société
or les journalistes politiques sont on
va dire des commentateurs sportifs
c'est un machin vous avez toujours plus
vite que je suis meilleur commentateur
meilleur commentateur ça je ne sais pas
ce que justement ça m'ennuie
profondément le commentaire sportif où
est donc bon mais cela comment vous dire
ce sont des spécialistes de la vie
politique des partis sauf que quand vous
regardez là aussi le fonctionnement
d'une rédaction canton il s'agit d'aller
interviewer un homme politique en vue on
se fout de savoir quelle est sa
spécialité on envoie les journalistes
politiques qui vont évidemment être
incapable de l'interroger sur les
réelles décisions politiques il prend
vous savez où dans une rédaction du
journal on est capable d'aller
interroger le ministre de l'éducation
nationale sans demander aux journalistes
spécialistes d'éducation ça arrive c'est
parce que ce qui compte c'est que les
journalistes politiques viennent lui
demander alors vous postulez à quoi et
alors quel est votre tactique pour
battre machin etc il ya que ça qui les
intéressent donc je pense aussi que fin
c'est ça explique beaucoup du
fonctionnement des du fonctionnement des
journaux vous voyez par delà les
questions purement
idéologique de fond dire que justement
malheureusement il n'y a pas d'idéologie
il n'y a pas de réflexion c'est déco qui
creusent sait où c'est simplement des
[__] afrique on court après le fric
alors après il ya des questions de
génération c'est à dire que
il ya eu toute une tradition du grand
journalisme politique à la française qui
d'ailleurs a bien du mal à comprendre
que la proximité avec son sujet peut
parfois être très très problématique
voilà donc mais les jeunes aujourd'hui
les jeunes journalistes ont tendance à
reproduire ça alors en étant un peu plus
mordants en étant un petit peu plus
rentre dedans
- dans la connivence mais tout de même
ils vont alors c'est pour le coup péché
par absence de culture politique absence
de culture historique qui leur interdira
ne serait-ce que de faire preuve du
minimum de mémoire qui me permet
d'interroger un homme politique sur ses
choix sur son parcours sur sur la
cohérence de ce qu'il fait parce que
c'est le principe de peter appliquez
votre profession
c'est possible c'est possible je pense
que c'est surtout et nous rappeler le
principe de peter est ce le principe de
peter c'est le principe de
d'incompétence c'est ce c'est l'idée que
c'est l'idée que on atteint au bout d'un
moment son seuil d'incompétence si je me
trompe c'est bien si mes souvenirs sont
bons c'est qu'on place les éléments les
plus incompétents et au poste parce que
c'est là où ils font moins de balles
voilà ce qu'on appelle l'éviction par le
haut aussi que j'ai vu beaucoup pratiqué
et c'est aussi le fait que
plus tôt dans ce principe il ya l'idée
que chacun va monter les échelons
jusqu'au moment où il ne pourra pas
monter parce qu'on voit qu'il a atteint
son seuil d'incompétence sauf qu'une
fois qu'il a atteint son seuil
d'incompétence mais il est là je ferai
des incompétents
est-ce que joffrin est incompétent je ne
dirais pas ça ça va je n'ai jamais
trouvé que les résultats qu'il avait
donné de tête des rédactions qui l'a
dirigé été fulgurant j'ai en termes
mêmes de nombre de lecteurs de ce
qu'elle fouillait développement d'un
titre après chez laurent joffrin il ya
un problème idéologique
moi j'ai du mal
avec quelqu'un qui considère que son
travail
est de faire en sorte d'abord de
défendre mordicus la politique d'un
président de la république qui a trahi
toutes ses promesses de campagne et
ensuite de criminaliser tout ce qui
pourrait éventuellement s'opposer à cela
ou faire valoir qu'il y à d'autres
politiques possibles façons jeté
l'opprobe sur les opinions qui lui est
en jeu c'est ça oui le traité carrément
de crypto fasciste à peu près tout ce
qui ne rentre pas dans le cadre on va
dire de la gentille social démocratie
qui d'ailleurs n'est même plus une
social démocratie mais du libéralisme
pur quand il me dit quand il me dit
énormément d'informations qui passe ya
pas de police de la pensée il n'y a pas
de cycle orwélien du journalisme oui ça
s'appelle se moquer du monde vous êtes
déconnecté
je pense que malheureusement ce genre de
personnage arrive très sincèrement a su
pas su persuader de ce qui me dit c'est
à dire que il est
convaincu qu'il est en lutte contre une
france nauséabonde parce que dans ces
cas là vous avez remarqué qu'il ya quand
même une sensibilité olfactive à ses
marques et enchaîne ses gens là c'est
toujours les adjectifs
olfactif kipré qui prévalent et donc
je pense qu'il est intimement convaincu
d'être dans le camp du bien face aux
[__]
vraiment et que il fait oeuvre de
salubrité publique en essayant à tout
prix d' empêcher que puisse surgir une
alternative ne comprenant pas évidemment
que sa façon de renvoyer au front
national toute personne qui ne pensent
pas exactement dans la ligne libérale
qui est la sienne laisse justement le
monopole de l'alternative politique au
front national mais après tout c'est ce
qui est recherché je pense c'est l'idée
que on va pour que on a besoin d'un
diable on va pouvoir agiter ce diable
étant qu'il existe on continue soit même
à exister
on va passer sur la politique étrangère
la france qui va intervenir un peu
partout la france qui a pu beaucoup de
sous des terroristes qui frappe
maintenant sur le territoire une
politique étrangère sans aucune remise
en question nous seulement sans aucune
remise en question mais qui poursuit
depuis des années maintenant un
alignement sur les états unis qui est la
négation absolue de tout ce qui avait
été sa tradition diplomatique et qui le
fait en plus pour les pires raison
qu'ils soient tout simplement parce
qu'il ya plus d'argent et parce que du
coup on pense qu'il faut aller prendre
les capitaux là où ils sont c'est à dire
en arabie saoudite et au qatar je crois
que très sincèrement que notre
diplomatie est dictée par notre besoin
d'argent et que pour faire illusion
ensuite on s'invente des guerres un peu
partout
en n'ayant pas d'ailleurs les moyens
suffisants pour les pour pour les mener
dans la mesure où le budget militaire a
été réduit de façon ahurissante
c'est mai
nettoyez nettoyer mais comme la posture
du chef de guerre ça marche encore en
france et que ça permet de gagner des
points dans les sondages tout à coup on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas mal l'armée
si vous aviez à vous positionner dans
cette phrase c'est cette politique qui
leur crève les yeux ou assez fou les
aveugles
honnêtement la phrase à ces politiques
qui leur crève les yeux ou à ces foules
aveugle
si j'interprète bien la phrase
il s'agit de savoir si c'est la
responsabilité
des politiques ou si c'est de la
responsabilité des gens qui acceptent
je pense que c'est un jeu en miroir je
pense que
les foules aveugle en effet
accepté depuis des années de se
dessaisir du pouvoir que leur avait
donné la démocratie c'est du
misérabilisme de l'impuissance
c'est
une forme de
on va dire de paresse de paresse
entretenu par tout un système c'est à
dire que je pense que le principe de la
société de consommation et de spectacle
évidemment de
d'encourager cette paresse de la faire
prospérer de des pubs de développer chez
les gens les pulsions immédiate
oui oui bien sûr le principe même de la
consommation
à travers un site et par la publicité
c'est ça c'est de jouer sur les pulsions
en lait en activant des stimuli pour
justement éviter toute toute réflexion
tout rotules on est dans la manipulation
pure quand
comme patrick le lay explique que son
métier consiste à vendre à coca cola du
temps de cerveau humain disponible il a
résumé le fonctionnement de la
démocratie aujourd'hui les gens sont qu
on les a rendus compte on fait en sorte
qu'il soit con moi j'ai énormément j'ai
une très très grande un très très grand
respect pour les savoirs
non scolaires les savoirs non
universitaires et je pense qu'il y a que
l'humanité a développé ses savoirs
pendant des siècles de façon admirable
j'entendais l'autre jour une rediffusion
des très vieux extrait de bonjour
monsieur le maire de pierre bonté ça
paraît totalement ringard ils allaient
dans le fin fond de la france paysanne
dans les années 60 et ils interrogeaient
des gens dont on comprenait qu'ils
avaient une intelligence et une masse de
culture absolument énorme énorme c'est
une culture qui a été éradiquée qui a
été radié par quoi par un triptyque
télévisions publicité grande
distribution ce qui a petit à petit
englué ces gens chez eux devant leur
télé en rompant tous les liens sociaux
qu'il pouvait avoir avec le monde qui
les entouraient et qui les a incités à
rêver de ce qu'ils allaient pouvoir
trouver le samedi au supermarché je
pense qu'il y à la une
une aliénation absolument monstrueuse
c7 catatonie émotionnel cru dans la
population parce c'était cet
anesthésique qui est la presse
ce show ce cirque créé maintenant
une incompréhension entre les flux de
migrants la douleur des milans la
souffrance des miron
ça va se matérialiser comme encore les
gens vont commencer à prendre conscience
de la réalité des souffrances mondial
qui se déplacent qui s'est mis en ordre
de marche ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux
ça peut extrait ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux parce que tout cela n'est
absolument pas penser préparer parce que
c'est habile et au doux et exercices
suisse à partir de 2012 fermeture
intégrale du territoire dgt ses
frontières contre un afflux massif de
migrants provenant d'espagne d'italie de
grèce de france
les militaires infléchissent quand même
un sens oui mais je pense que les
politiques ne réfléchissent pas je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de réflexion politique
sur ce qu'implique des déplacements de
populations qui ont été en grande partie
causée par des décisions
occidental absolument délirante
cher nous sommes en tête quand même de
payer la guerre d'irak la guerre de
libye qui ont déstabilisé totalement des
pays et dans une arène juillet
irresponsabilité totale donc aujourd'hui
cette souffrance provoquée
va déstabiliser
mécaniquement les sociétés européennes
et tout cela n'est vraiment pas
anticiper que vous croyez à la
balkanisation de l'europe oui je le cas
je le crains je crains qu'il y ait un
éclatement total des nations et des
luttes violentes parce qu'on voit monter
la violence aujourd'hui on voit que dans
l'ensemble des pays européens
il y a des radicalisations de toutes
parts chaque chaque
quand idéologiques ethniques se
radicalise
et montre de moins en moins d'empathie
de moins en moins de capacité à penser
les choses politiquement
donc je crains énormément que dans
l'avenir il puisse y avoir des
véritablement des
des éruptions de violence on sait très
bien l'histoire nous montre qu'une
société censément civilisé peut basculer
dans la barbarie est extrêmement
rapidement
écoutez moi je ne pense pas que tout
aille bien mais tant qu'on a des
dirigeants qu'ils se rassurent en
s'imaginant qu'ils sentiront et en y
réfléchissant pas plus plus loin qu'à un
ou deux mois ou au mieux à l'élection
suivante ça continuera mais très
honnêtement je pense que c'est pour ça
que notre responsabilité notamment en
tant que journaliste et d'essayer de
penser le temps long c'est d'essayer
justement de décrypter des mouvements
qui sont des mouvements intellectuels
des mouvements de pensée des mouvements
de deux d'opinion bien plus vaste
mais pour ça ça nécessite d'abord de
prendre le temps de réfléchir
ça nécessite aussi la culture suffisante
justement pour être capable de faire le
lien entre les événements
changer de sujet eduardo donne ça vous
fait penser à quoi
comment vous dire à quoi ça me fait
penser
ça me fait penser d'abord à une forme de
lâcheté terrible de la france oui dans
la façon dont a été gérée
enfin dans le dans la façon dont la
france a refusé
de lui venir en aide l'asile
oui oui
que vous dire de plus
là et mes soeurs
je pense que nous avons totalement
renoncé à
faire prévaloir
on va dire une indépendance
donc journalistes différents pour vous
faites comment pour protéger vos sources
la caste journalistique ne s'est pas
chiffrer ses mails la case chantal
eastick une connaissance parcellaire ou
voir vaporiser de milieux numérique
j'ai beaucoup discuté avec eux leur
expliquer que la confidentialité d'une
enquête c'est important que vous pouvez
mettre en danger toute une salle de
rédaction avec une demi clé usb ils sont
complètement à l'ouest c est ce qu il ya
des cours mais je connais je connais
deux journalistes dans le numérique qui
font correctement leur boulot et on ne
manifeste pas trop ce père jean marc
manach y ait amar crise viala doute mais
ces deux-là essaye de prêcher un petit
peu leurs confrères
vous savez chiffres et un mail bien sûr
mais vous savez moi je suis pas je suis
pas de journaliste d'investigation mais
vous êtes présidente d'un son temps que
maintenant c'est vrai est donc en effet
je pense que quand on est journaliste
d'investigation il y a ce genre de
précautions à prendre mais je vais être
très honnête avec vous moi ma pratique
journalistique elle est d'un autre ordre
sert qu'il ya différentes formes de
journalisme jeunes un coin je n'incarne
pas le journalisme d'investigation
moi je suis quelqu'un qui essaye de on
va dire de penser le monde tout
simplement et 2
d'en décrypter les
les mouvements idéologiques
alors ce que donne ses cours est un
mouvement idéologique c'est la
réminiscence de la sphère farwell mais
côté américain cette fois ci c'est
qu'est ce que c'est et c'est la
révélation
absolue d'une forme d'impérialisme
extrêmement puissant et extrêmement
violent
d'une
on va dire du
d'un rouleau compresseur
malgré tout sous les apparences
débonnaire d'une va dire d'une puissance
en temps de paix
on a récemment interviewé le le ministre
conseiller d'ambassade de russie puis
juste après son patron l'ambassadeur
alexandre orlov ambassadeur la
fédération aussi bon comme on est un peu
taquin on a appelé les agréent qui en
arrière alors à proposer le même deal
avec les mêmes choses et on s'est rendu
compte que pour avoir une interview de
l'ambassadrice américaine s'était déjà
dix minutes maximum
et qu'il fallait c'était mieux d'envoyer
les questions juste avant
quand on leur a dit qu'on venait de
youtube et qu'on procédait pas comme ça
que toutes les interactions qu'on allait
avoir et que à l'aide publique ils ont
commencé à tousser
comment ça se fait que journaliste
accepte d'aller je vais pas dire tapie
n'est pas ce que donnait ces questions
avant ces tapis ne sais quoi
alors c'est compliqué ça dépend ça
dépend dans quel cadre et puis ça dépend
si c'est toutes les questions ou vous
donner et 6 a interdit les relances
après vous voyez c'est à dire est ce que
j'ai déjà eu à donner mes questions
avant n'ont jamais mais en tout cas
pente et braskem quoi vous donner les
axes genre non dits géopolitique
internet finances mais pas plus pas plus
donnez les questions avant cette farce
comment vous dire
[Musique]
non j'essaie de réfléchir à comment on
peut biaiser face à ça parce que qu une
ambassadrice américaine réclame qu'on
lui donne les questions avant ça ne me
surprendrait quand même pas je préfère
c'est préférable oui et bien sûr on est
bien d'accord
deux bus de même que j'ai déjà vu des
cabinets de ministres expliquait alors
non pas qu'ils voulaient les questions
avant mais enfin que quand même si on
pouvait leur expliquer exactement avant
ce qu'il allait se passer et terrasses
étaient c'était mieux
ya toujours moyen de donner deux trois
trucs et de voiliers serre que
je ça ne m'étonne pas qu'ils jouent leur
partition là c'est que la question c'est
est ce que le journaliste en face
accepte de rentrer totalement dans le
jeu ou est ce qu ils biaisent
donc là en l'occurrence dans un cadre
comme le vôtre où vous êtes dans une
interview vous pouvez pas accepter ça
sinon vous vous privez de l'interview de
fin mais sans doute vaut-il mieux se
priver de l'interview que d'avoir une
langue de bois absolue ouais ouais c'est
tout s'est positionné comme conseil pour
quand même y aller
on va vous expliquer rapide à on a on a
on a ajouté axel le maire pendant la loi
renseignement qui voulait pas répondre
des commandes à une forte communauté de
hackers geek derrière nous et qu'on est
fortement
enracinée dans cette guilde on lui a
posé clairement les choses un lundi nous
on va dire qu'on a essayé de vous parler
même si vous 6 l 100 mille personnes qui
débarquent sur deux conducteurs on sera
pas responsables quand ils ont vu nos
partenaires ils ont dit oups et ils ont
plaidé que les partenaires comptent 2
millions de visiteurs uniques par mois
on s'est compliqué à la jouer la
transparence elle a tenu sa parole dans
les autres ministères se compliquer donc
est ce que vous nous conseillez de
continuer à faire les mercenaires
oui vous avez bien sûr bien sûr mais ça
sont je pense que vous avez une arme
absolue qui est le caractère
immédiatement mesurable de votre
puissance
c'est tout la presse écrite n'a plus
tout à fait ça la presse classique quand
je dis presse écrite c'est aussi radio
télé et sur des choses beaucoup moins
comment dire beaucoup moins immédiat que
ne peuvent l'être les réseaux sociaux
donc si le rapport de force s'inverse il
faut pas hésiter à l'utiliser c'est un
rapport de force
l'information il faut aller là il faut
aller la chercher
lahlou questionnement une île et il peut
être violent et il doit l'être parfois
donc on peut s'engueuler encore on peut
s'en mettre plein la tête vraie joute
oratoire mais j'espère mais j'espère
bien le drame aujourd'hui c'est que la
plupart des gens n'acceptent de venir
débattre qu'avec ceux avec qui sont déjà
d'accord vous voudriez débattre avec
acrimed oui bien sûr tout de suite oui
d'accord bien sûr moi j'ai aucun
problème
si vous aviez laissé un conseil aux
jeunes générations vos bouteilles à la
mer sur internet nous ne le prisme à
moyen terme à long terme on essaie de
déconne détecter les signaux faibles et
on essayait aussi laissé des
préconisations
la jeunesse qui fument des pétards à 3
heures du matin et carrières des
émissions de géopolitique un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
lisez thucydide
vraiment
je peux vous dire que salies lisez et en
particulier réviser l'histoire antique
l'histoire romaine l'histoire grecque
c'est une c'est une manne pour
comprendre justement ce que c'est
réellement que la géopolitique ce que
c'est que les rapports de force quand
vous lisez dans la guerre du péloponnèse
la façon dont athènes a traité la petite
île de mélo ce qu'ils voulaient rester
neutre dans la guerre qu'ils ne
voulaient pas
surtout pas se mêler du conflit et
catane leur a dit mais attendez nous on
veut pas de neutralité si vous n'êtes
pas avec nous vous êtes contre nous ils
ont envahi et ils ont réduit en
esclavage toute la population mais c'est
une explication absolument
extraordinaire du mode de fonctionnement
de l'impérialisme
si vous si vous regardez le
fonctionnement d'athènes la façon dont
ils appliquent et dont ils sont très
fiers d'appliquer en leur sein la
démocratie mais la façon dont ils
traitent leurs alliés vous comprenez
d'abord
je sais que voilà que ce ne sont pas des
alliés mais des subordonnés et ça vous
rappelle un impérialisme actuelle assez
marquées et ensuite ça vous explique
pourquoi ça s'est effondrée parce que ça
finit par s'effondrer
ségolène royal au quai d'orsay ce vous
fait penser à quoi
la bravitude
c'est ouais ouais
j'avais d'autres choses à nous poser des
questions à poser mon vous à votre tour
des questions oui oui bien sûr
vous êtes nos journalistes et vous êtes
extrêmement critique sur le journalisme
ce que je comprends parfaitement
et je me suis aussi
est ce que pour autant
vous estimez qu'il faut que la presse et
les médias tels qu'ils existent
disparaissent oui oui à 100 %
il en fait je vais déléguer je vais
delhi la réponse
quand vous avez trahi la confiance de
quelqu'un
jamais vous ne pouvez revenir en arrière
oui ça je crois que c'est vrai
je crois que c'est vrai en même temps
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il ya moyen
aujourd'hui en tout cas de réfléchir à
une façon de développer sur le net
l'ensemble de ce qu'apporte je disais
tout à l'heure que je pense que pour
l'instant le travail que fait le
journalisme de presse écrite notamment
on le trouve pas sur le net sous la même
forme c'est vrai je le pense
pour autant je pense qu'à terme de toute
façon ça se passera on est dans une
phase de transition
est ce que moi je viens chercher dans la
presse je crois que ça peut surgir aussi
de diverses manières sur le net
simplement
c'est un modèle économique c'est une
question de modèle économique
comment on arrive à faire vivre ça pour
l'instant malheureusement il faut
beaucoup d'argent pour payer un type qui
a offert un reportage au long cours
voilà c'est ça ne ne sais pas si on a
trouvé la solution pour que ce soit
rentable et d'autres questions à nous
poser
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas
vous je pense que nous n'avons pas la
même culture
comment dire je très honnêtement je n'ai
pas une culture des nouvelles
technologies je n'ai pas
pour l'instant je n'ai pas eu le temps
de m'intéresser suffisamment à ces
problématiques et à toutes ces à toute
l'implication que ça peut avoir sur les
questions de notamment le journalisme
d'investigation
enfin c'est pas que ça m'intéresse pas
je vis et je me suis intéressé mais pas
autant que je le voudrais c'est à dire
que je ne serai jamais péremptoires sur
ces questions là parce que j'estime que
il y a des choses encore des choses que
je ne maîtrise pas suffisamment j'ai une
culture trop classique pour ça je sais
pas encore c'est quoi une culture trop
classique
on va dire que je suis quelqu'un de
l'écrit et met véritablement quelqu'un
qui va s'intéresser spontanément ou
récit
à la pensée à la
à l'idéologie
voilà je suis
je suis profondément je pense imprégné
de culture littéraire et de culture
historique et c'est pour ça que je pense
que j'ai envie d'ouvrir le comité orwell
à des journalistes qui auront un autre
type de culture que la mienne c'est à
dire kg seront bien plus au fait de des
modes de fonctionnement
des réseaux sociaux vous voyez tout ce
qui concerne le hacking par exemple est
quelque chose qui m'échappe je ne sais
pas comment ça fonctionne mais
fonctionne très simplement bien sûr mais
enfin quand les choses ne sont jamais
simples j'aime comprendre j'aime
comprendre jusqu'au bout donc quand on
cherche à comprendre ça n'est jamais
simple ou quand on est passionné fait
toujours simple voilà j'ai peut-être une
petite question encore
la formation de très haute qualité dont
vous rêvez vous que vous professez
l'information qui fait appel à
l'intelligence des gens comment
peut-elle être mise en place dans un
système où les médias sont à but
lucratif est en concurrence
c'est toute l'ambivalence bien sûr c'est
à dire que ce je le disais tout à
l'heure ce sont ce sont des entreprises
mais ce ne sont pas des entreprises
comme les autres donc ça ne peut
fonctionner que dans un système où il ya
un public éclairé qui a envie de payer
pour cette information pour cette
réflexion de qualité yat il encore
aujourd'hui un public de lecteurs
natacha
le principe de catatonie intellectuelle
c'est simple vous mettez quelqu'un sous
pression ful harcelé de peine et de mot
crise financière perte de boulot
problèmes à l'école terrorisme aux
crises nucléaires pollution pesticides
et on en passe et des meilleures qu'est
ce qui se passe rien et un effet de
repli tout le monde le sait demain les
gens déjà éclairé le savent et quand on
extrapole l'on extrapole le raisonnement
on sait pertinemment que ce sont des
belles paroles de dire qu' on ne peut
avoir qu un public éclairé mais il y en
a de moins en moins elle a dit nyan win
nous on a la dynamique de lâcher prise
c'est à dire que
on vous laisse encore une chance vous
les journalistes de laver votre honneur
de laver votre profession le cercle le
cercle en rouelles pour nous le comité
romaine au départ on l'a un peu mal pris
que vous appelez les comme ça parce que
ces lourdes symbolique pour nous et on
s'est dit quand même ils essayent de
survivre ils essaient de se réveiller
alors c'est peut-être pas tous les
journalistes et qu' il y en a une qui a
décidé de sortir parce qu'elle a une
paire de baloche un peu plus endurcis
que la majeure partie de sa caste
et on vous laisse faire on va peut-être
essayer de vous aider regardez la
profession journalistique avec un peu
plus de bienveillance mais après vous
serez relégué définitivement avec les
politiques et lobbyistes et ainsi de
suite vous allez devenir la cible
vraiment de jean pertinent sur l'outil
numérique ça risque de très mal se
passer donc battez vous
oui battez vous mais d'abord je vais
vous dire une chose je ne me suis jamais
senti à partenaires aucune casse toi qu
aucune corporation
je n'ai pas l'esprit de caste vous
n'avez jamais acheté deux voitures avec
votre carte de presse
d'accord
c'est pourquoi on achète une voiture
avec une carte de passe que vous pouvez
acheter une machine aussi avec une carte
d'après son
nom
je vous conseille un christian ramade
très complet vous appelez vous appelez
dit vous êtes journaliste dans une carte
de presse hop là une réduction allez je
savais pas vous me l'apprenez c'est
sympa on peut en profiter ah bah ouais
c'est ce que vous voulez mais je sais
non voyagé j'ai loupé des trucs c'est
comme quoi les journalistes sont quand
même parfois les moyens d'informer ça
sérieusement
sérieusement non non je ne sais pas je
dois avoir d'abord un vieux fonds
d'éducation de perdre tout ça de moi
j'ai une éducation un peu janséniste il
ya des trucs qui se font pas bon ben
voilà non c'est et honnêtement je n'ai
jamais eu l'esprit de corps j'ai été
prof aussi j'étais pas plus corporatiste
côté profs que côté journalistes voilà
donc comment ça je ne me sens absolument
pas comptable de ce que font les
journalistes en général ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir comment moi
je vais essayer de faire mon boulot à
peu près honnêtement et de faire en
sorte
je suis plus journaliste au figaro je
suis chroniqueuse extérieur ne suis pas
salarié delà de la rédaction j'ai
d'ailleurs je ne mets pas les pieds
parce que je ne suis pas journaliste au
figaro je les ai été pendant trois ans
que sur les questions d'éducation que le
comité aurait on vous a objecté que vous
travaillez pour l'arche en garde c'est
quoi votre avis là-dessus mon avis est
que malheureusement aujourd'hui en effet
une bonne partie des médias
appartiennent à des grands groupes
industriels et en particulier des
groupes des groupes de qui vendent des
armes plutôt que de objecté le figaro on
aurait pu m'objecter d'ailleurs europe 1
où l'a d'ailleurs je suis pas plus
salariés enfin je suis pas plus en cdi
mais je suis salarié pour le coup
simplement
j'ai commencé mon travail de journaliste
à marianne qui est un des rares journaux
indépendants et j'en ai gardé l'idée que
en effet dans un monde idéal il fallait
aller vers les médias qui étaient les
plus indépendants et que ça permettait
plus de liberté pour autant
d'abord c'est quand même à marianne que
je me suis fait placardisé pour mes
idées à partir du départ de jean
françois kahn
le journal s'est recentrée vers quelque
chose gentiment gauche bien pensante
social démocrate donc j'avais plus ma
place voilà alors que
au figaro j'ai pu subir quand j'étais
journaliste sur les questions
d'éducation dire tout le mal que je
pensais des loi chatel je me suis jamais
fait taper sur les doigts la seule fois
où je me suis fait taper sur les doigts
c'était c'était quand j'étais invité
comme éditorialiste sur les plateaux de
télévision moi qui n'étais que
rubricards d'éducation ce qui fait
partie des hasards de la vie bon ça
s'est trouvé comme ça et
taper sur les doigts ça c'est grave à
rester camper sur les doigts non c'était
un coup de téléphone
d'un supérieur hiérarchique me disant
écoute la prochaine fois essaye d'y
aller mollo caen il s'appelle je ne
balance pas les supérieurs hiérarchiques
non ça je j'estime que ça se fait pas
non voilà mais il suffit de savoir que
ses supérieurs hiérarchiques au figaro
nom s'est jamais démentie sur le nom sur
internet on pourra peut-être essayer de
lui envoyer un petit mail pour le
remercier non mais vous savez sur quel
sujet c'était la guerre en libye voilà
pour changer parce que je m'étais chez
le ch était sur le plateau de thierry
ardisson et que j'avais
j'étais là pour parler bioéthique parce
que leurs invités c'était rené frydman
et il avait invité deux personnalités
amis de rené frydman donc l'abbé de la
morandais et bernard kouchner et il se
trouve que la discussion arrive c'était
pile au moment où la france commencé à
intervenir en libye et bernard a sorti
son sac de riz ben voilà et il a
expliqué que c'était merveilleux et
qu'on allait sauver le monde la
démocratie pour les petites filles là et
là je fais écouter ça me paraît quand
même un petit peu présomptueux excusez
moi on a fait quelques ânes riz en irak
on n'est peut-être pas obligé non plus
de recommencer et de recommencer en
étant persuadé que cette fois ci ça va
être merveilleux donc le minimum c'est
d'avoir un tout petit peu de prudence et
là ils m'ont tous regardé en se
demandant d'où sortait
c'était il y avait un côté comme neige
avait fait intrusion dans un dîner de
gens bien et
et qu'il a invité celle là d'ailleurs ça
a été la question après non mais
pourquoi mais pourquoi mais il faut
inviter des gens sérieux quand même un
petit peu voilà mais ça m'a valu de me
retrouver à on n'est pas couché
puisque catherine barma était devant sa
télé et s'est dit tiens au moins elle
une sait tenir tête voilà c'était c'est
comme ça que je me suis retrouvée on
n'est pas couché ce que vous avez déjà
réussi à le faire partir à m'inviter
à l'horizon jacques attali je les ai pas
eus ar on n'est pas couché jacques
attali non non chez mes beaux jacques
attali part souvent je passais de le
faire une petite expérience les gens qui
quittent les plateaux sont des
récidivistes donc il n'y a pas grande
gloire à compenser un peu la terre non
moi le seul qui soit parti quand j'étais
on n'est pas couché christophe
hondelatte
là-bas et je n'en ai toujours sinon est
conçu j'aimais beaucoup ce jour à
l'autre elle était très marrant oui mais
et c'est même ça a même été très négatif
parce que ça
c'était volontaire de sa part c'était
une façon de mettre ça sur jouer sur
scène et
du coup ça a donné l'impression je
venais d'arriver on n'est pas couché ça
ça a donné l'impression à beaucoup de
gens que évidemment cette émission était
là pour faire du clash et que j'étais
moi même
évidemment une partie de ce système un
support et donc ça à décrédibiliser
totalement mon travail et j'ai été
obligé de ramer après pour essayer de
montrer que mon but n'était pas de faire
du clash mais de débattre et d'essayer
de penser les problèmes de façon un peu
pertinente et honnête si vous aviez une
équipe
task force de de la matière grise à
former vous mettez en liquide dans
des gens que vous connaissez pas
forcément
une équipe à former mais c'est à face à
des bandes idées pour former formés pour
faire croire l'agencé tous risques de
l'information agence tous risques de
l'information hannibal hannibal qui qui
assumerait hannibal
écoutez je sais pas il ya des ya
quelques personnes que je respecte
beaucoup parmi les journalistes
aujourd'hui et les européens forcément
oui pourquoi pas et puis voyez quelqu'un
comme vanessa ratinier par exemple qui a
travaillé avec pierre péan sur sur le
qatar est quelqu'un que je respecte et
que j'apprécie c'est ce genre de
personne que j'aurais envie de faire
travailler si je pouvais me choisir une
équipe c'est vous
impossible de la faire entrer en équipe
dans laquelle
vous avez quelques heures ouais commencé
par annoncer me suffira
d'accord savez ça j'en ai croisé je sens
mes phrases est tellement belle journée
des cibles des cibles mais il faut que
cette pas par sylvain maintenant c'est à
dire que c'est pas une question de
l'acheter c'est que je me fous des
personnes furent c'est pour moi c'est
totalement anecdotique le vecteur
d'idées cc c'est le principe le principe
c'est la personne certes le messager
n'est rien par rapport au message
quand vous êtes dans un théâtre
d'opérations il faut savoir aussi
neutraliser les vecteurs vous vous
faites vous les journalistes vous faites
neutralisé dans une phase ont accepté ou
du moins la plupart se font neutraliser
ou consciemment ou avec leur aval
dont neutralise les vecteurs c'est notre
plaisir quand vous avez un journaliste
qui est vecteur d'une mauvaise
information et d'une information qui est
biaisé où commencent à s'intéresser aux
journalistes et on court circuit de ce
vecteur là vous avez pas un petit
nouveau à vous dire celui
[Rires]
honnêtement c'est pas voyez moi ma façon
de fonctionner
mais c'est une faune qu'une façon
aussi c'est un tort sans doute très
individuelle parce que c'est peut-être
parce que j'ai un parcours un peu à part
ma façon de fonctionner ça a toujours
été de faire mon boulot du mieux que je
pouvais en suivant une ligne le lead
idéologique en défendant les valeurs qui
sont les miennes les idées qui sont les
miennes il se trouve que j'ai eue le bol
de profiter d'un système audio visuel
qui a besoin de mettre des femmes je
suis bénéficiaire de la discrimination
possible de la discrimination positive
de la parité c'est d'autres disent
qu'ils ne sont plus de moi je suis
contre la discrimination positive
je pense que il est nécessaire que
l'ensemble de la population soient
représentés dans les médias comme
ailleurs mais que c'est pas par la
discrimination positive qu'il faut le
faire vous êtes vous assurez vous
assumez vos opinions
vous avez une garde rapprochée contre
les terroristes
est ce que vous comprenez que certains
journalistes soient protégés par l'état
dhr
et foot et surtout en ce moment s'ils
ont reçu des menaces de mort oui il me
semble que ça enfin je ne sais pas je
comprends que
ce que vous pensez que ce dispositif est
suffisamment
puissant pour protéger nos journalistes
ceux qui font leur boulot
est ce qu'on m'a mise suffisamment de
moyens pour protéger les femmes
journalistes
non non je vais enfin je sais que je
pense que on a vu que tout dispositif de
protection
toute façon avait peu de chance de
naître de faire face à des attaques de
personnes déterminées mais
je pense que
c'est
la fin comment dire ça dépend de quel de
quelle menace vous parle de quel type de
menaces et de kehl
alors nous on fait de la veille aussi
sur les terroristes et on voit beaucoup
de réseaux s'activer sur les femmes
journalistes
et on trouve que l'on met pas assez le
paquet pour les protéger et on en
profite pour faire passer un message
oui c'est possible je pense que
l'on va encore manger pour 30 ans vous
savez ça c'est ça c'est sûr c'est sûr
que l'on parle d'eux par le problème de
très long terme
mais je crains malheureusement que la
protection même si elle est nécessaire
ne soit jamais totalement suffisante
vous savez d'ordre non mais comme je
suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement
comment dire certains diraient anxieux
d'autres peut-être le cid et que je suis
en pleine réflexion sur
réflexion limite fascination sur le
survivalisme
pourquoi fascination non c'est une façon
parler je plaisante mais c'est mes jeux
j'ai toujours
était très intéressé par les réflexions
qui essaye d'anticiper ce que peut être
le
justement la chute d'une civilisation ne
serait ce que parce que j'ai conscience
que c'est parfaitement possible que ça
peut arriver et donc qui m'arrive de
temps en temps de me dire que
je
j'aimerais savoir manier une arme et que
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
tue-t-il en plus quand j'étais petit mon
père membre non mais
toujours dans un cadre légal mais bien
entendu mais j'ai très petit j'ai
arpenté les clubs de tir pour tirer à la
carabine quelle était votre caddie
préférées enfin l'époque j'étais petit
je me sens 65 ans j'avais 6 ans
natacha polony merci et au plaisir de
vous revoir sur notre chaîne youtube
merci de votre invitation
[Musique]
non